je vous le rappelle donc des pourparlers
premiers échanges directs entre les
ministres russe et ukrainien des
affaires étrangères au mieux ce matin en
territoire turc antalya cette conférence
de presse a eu dans deux salles
distinctes le ministre ukrainien qu'on a
pu su dans un premier temps c'est
évidemment exprimé a rendu compte de
cette heure et demie d'échangés 1h30
d'entretien at il dit dmitri cool et
baky qui a estimé finalement que la
proposition humanitaire formulées par
les écrits n'y en avait pas avancé d'un
iota il estime que kiev a donc proposé à
moscou un cessez le feu de 24 heures le
russe sergueï lavrov n'aurait pas
répondu le gouvernement ukrainien qui
réitère qu'il qu'il ne se rendra pas ça
gagne la drogue qui lui parallèlement
était en train de s'adresser aux
journalistes qui qu'il écoutait sa gay
lavrov qui évidemment un son de cloche
un peu différente d'un jeune garçon va
on va décrypter tout cela a estimé que
la russie a elle aussi était prête à
négocier a évoqué cette question
humanitaire qui a été largement
interrogé sur les frappes de marioupol
hier cette maternité et cet hôpital dont
les circonstances sont encore très
floues lui parle de fait news il estime
que le site avait été repris par par les
séparatistes et craignant qu'il n'y
avait aucun patient sur site voilà les
russes qui officiellement son accord
pour négocier mais qui n'ont pas avancé
non plus hein oui finalement en fait le
mérite de cette de cette rencontre c'est
qu'elle a eu lieu et point à la ligne on
a eu véritablement de narratif deux
explications différentes et on se
demande même si les deux hommes ont
participé à une réunion et se sont se
sont parlé d'un côté vous avez
effectivement enfin le seul point commun
c'est qu'ils sont prêts ont-ils dit tous
les deux dans certaines conditions à se
revoir donc c'est à dire qu'ils font
passer le message qu'ils sont prêts au
dialogue et les mêmes lacunes composé à
sergueï lavrov à ce que les présidents
ukrainien heureuse pour pourraient se
rencontrer voilà mais là dessus
là-dessus sergueï lavrov le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères a aussi
été très clair il a dit que l'essentiel
des négociations politiques se tenait à
la frontière biélorusse que c'était des
gosses qui négocia sion direct entre les
russes et les ukrainiens qu'il n'y avait
pas de négociations parallèles échos
finalement s'il était venu là à antalya
c'était aussi à la demande des turcs
parce qu'il faisait confiance ou au
gouvernement turc mais il n'y a pas
véritablement de naves pas forcément
fait proposition ce qui était
intéressante il a venus avec des
propositions concrètes l'évolution est
dit que les ukrainiens ont pris en
compte ces propositions qui vont
réfléchir et qu'ils répondent enfin il a
dit il a dit des propositions ont été
faites nous attendons des réponses
évidemment à qui s'adressent les
réponses qu'il fait à la communauté
internationale mais aussi aux à la
population à la population russe
pour montrer ses mots c'est une façon de
montrer aussi que des efforts sont faits
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il a
maintenu son le narratif russe qu'on
connaît depuis maintenant plusieurs mois
à savoir il ne s'agit pas d'une guerre
il s'agit d'une opération spéciale
destinée à sauver des populations dit-il
russophone en ukraine qui sont otages
est évidemment ceci n'est pas une
explication tenable ceci est une un
narratif mais qui ne correspond pas à la
réalité il s'agit effectivement d'une
guerre à un moment donné un des
journaleux je crois de skynews disait
mais comment peuvent pouvons-nous
comment pouvons-nous vous faire
confiance sur tous les points quand vous
ne reconnaissez pas déjà le fait d'être
dans une non seulement d'enfin pas dans
une opération spéciale mais qu'il s'agit
véritablement d'une attaque ensuite en
dehors de sur la question de mario paul
et de l'hôpital pour le moment moi
personnellement je n'ai pas d'éléments
ce qu'on peut dire en revanche c'est que
en dehors de cet hôpital des
installations civiles ont été touchées
un petit peu partout dans les villes qui
sont maintenant à siéger au point que la
commune de la cour pénale internationale
l'allemagne et l'espagne ont décidé de
lancer des enquêtes pour crimes de
guerre le premier ministre espagnol qui
vient d'ailleurs à pendant cette
conférence de presse qui reprend les
termes de volodymyr zelensky qualifiant
la tacc de marioupol il hier de crimes
de guerre on reviendra sur ce qui s'est
passé là-bas avec vous marié laberge
dans quelques instants je ne sais pas si
ludovic de foucault en direct dans tayac
et donc notre correspondant en turquie
est avec nous pas encore d'un dicton
virginie on ne sait pas si on peut faire
confiance aux russes un peu la question
que vous soulevez il ya quelques
instants sergueï lavrov qui est
d'ailleurs toujours en train de
s'exprimer faut savoir que la partie
ukrainienne elle a terminé sa conférence
de pressse ya déjà plus d'une demi heure
on lui a demandé à plusieurs reprises
qu'elles sont sous vos intentions
vis-à-vis des occidentaux lui qui charge
dont chaque phrase quasiment ou presque
l'occident l'ouest avez vous l'intention
d'attaquer des pays qui notamment armes
les ukrainiens il y a nombre de pays au
sein de l'union européenne qui prêtent
main forte militairement en termes de
matériel c'est ces derniers jours est-ce
que vous avez l'intention d'entrer aussi
dans une troisième 3ème guerre mondiale
la guerre nucléaire ça c'est les
questions qui ont été posées de façon
très concrète oui absolument et
concrètement il a dit non absolument pas
il s'est mis dans une position défensive
en disant que si quelqu'un a faim si
ceux qui parlent de troisième guerre
mondiale ce sont plutôt les occidentaux
et les américains qui parlent de guerre
totale dans dans ce conflit occidentaux
qui quand même ont rappelons le livre
peut être des armes mais ont refusé la
zone d'exclusion aérienne pour protéger
les populations
ukrainienne comme l'a demandé le
président ukrainien qui pour le moment
refuse également de livrer des avions
des avions de chasse notamment aux
ukrainiens et qui sont dans une position
extrêmement ambiguë par rapport à ça qui
par contre effectivement ont pris des
sanctions économiques économique
notamment donc le narratif plus une fois
de plus c'est de dire la russie a posé
des conditions très claires nous sommes
menacés depuis des années par les
occidentaux par l'ouest par l'otan en
particulier et nos exigences sont une
ukraine totalement démilitarisées
qu'elle soit ou non dans l'otan et des
nazis cieux 6 eisel aurélien reprises à
chaque c'est une rhétorique qui
effectivement qui a justifié au départ
l'intervention cette intervention russe
poutine l'a dit dans son discours au
moment de leur lancement entre
guillemets de l'opéra de la population
spéciale et qui de toute façon si enfin
je sais pas si on va avoir le temps d'en
parler maintenant mais qui n'a
absolument aucun fondement